[Applause]
1951.
this year i love lucy premiered on
television
guess what else happened
the first direct dial coast-to-coast
telephone call was made wow i know think
about that when you get irritated with
your cell phone
and we're having a halloween party and
who better to help than my friend and
one cool kitten chef pilar valdes
okay
what 1950s treats are we making today
first up
the ultimate showstopper a baked alaska
that is so 1950s
it is
so
this dessert is basically layers of ice
cream
with a chocolate or brownie base
wrapped in a meringue and then toasted
so
shall we yes all right so first off you
have a ramekin that's lined with a
little bit of plastic wrap and you're
gonna fill in we did two layers of ice
cream we did strawberry and chocolate
and the last layer is actually gonna be
a chocolate mint chip
and then drew we have a little bit of a
brownie on this plate and do we put it
on top and you put it on top and that
becomes the base and basically what
you're going to do is freeze this for a
few hours until it firms up
and when you unmold it
oh my gosh it's upside down it's upside
down so you're going to flip it over
take out the ramekin peel off the
plastic and drew over here
in your bowl over there
you have a little bit of meringue it's a
very like marshmallowy
and you cook this
you cook this on like a pot like kind of
a double boiler bain marie
it's egg white sugar cream of tartar and
some salt
and we're gonna put that on our little
ice cream
beautiful
and if you guys aren't ready to serve it
yet you can actually just stick it back
in the freezer until you're ready to
to bake it off or torch it off so back
in the day they actually used to bake
this you can still do that 500 degrees
four minutes until it gets golden brown
and now we can actually torch it modern
day this is what you got me really
excited about okay all right one
two
i'm going to click this towards you
this guy
got it i got it i got her off to the
races
oh my gosh look that's so gratifying
look how beautiful that is guys that's
gorgeous can i invite my daddy out
absolutely
oh daddy-o
would you like some uh
[Applause]
ponytail dessert ready
okay is this the one you were licking
just out of curiosity
no ok
i swear this one has been never touched
okay i'll tell you about that i am a
wholesome traditional man i like my
desserts room temperature and vanilla so
i'm going to take a
real risk here
yeah
i'm going to cut into this guy consider
me converted
what
boy am i glad i married you
i told you i'd make you happy
sorta
okay fuller
my best partner in culinary crime what's
next so we have three um
treats over here in 1950s inspired so
all the rage in 1950s jello and jello
molds the jello was very popular because
it was insane it was new so we have this
no-bake
jelly cheesecake which is kind of
incredible how do you have a no-bake
cheesecake we use the gelatin to set it
basically it's really good and then we
did a ginger snap
and graham cracker crust so it's really
really delicious as you can see we get
to try it i think you can too shall we
try
so gelatin
and uh-huh and what is the how do you
make the cheesecake the cheesecake is a
little bit of um sour cream a little bit
of cream cheese and then a little bit of
that gelatin to set it well it looks
like drew likes her cheesecake like she
likes her husband's just a little fruity
[Laughter]
[Applause]
man ross and okay still be married right
there the whole time oh no a girl
um
wait polar but you tell me about the
candy apples too because there was a
really interesting spin on those as well
as the caramel okay so our last two
treats
we have uh candied apples which actually
when they first made these the person
who made them used to dip them in a
cinnamon syrup and they were really used
to just attract people he didn't think
that he was gonna actually sell them but
they were very popular and people
started buying them we did a little bit
of a twist on this and we did a balsamic
uh candied apple cute
thank you i'm scared to do it i know
i'm like i don't trust my teeth on these
i'm cheering you guys on
welcome
you're dead
i can't believe it it's amazing it's
really nice like balsamic caramel guys
is really delicious yeah what what did
you do to the caramel cream because you
put an ingredient in there that i
absolutely love so the last one is our
take on a classic cracker jack and it's
a miso caramel corn whoa whoa is the
word
mm-hmm
oh
my
caramel balsamic
apples yum
[Applause]
um drew wants me to tell you all to go
to the drewberrymore show.com for the
recipes for all these treats and a big
thanks to pilar
[Applause]
[Music]
you